un bonsoir et bienvenue dans le journal
de tv 78 nous sommes le mercredi 28
avril voici les titres de cette édition
l'expérimentation va durer plusieurs
années un écho score doit renseigner sur
l'impact environnemental des produits
alimentaires est la disposition fait
partie du projet de loi climat et
résilience et des applications haut des
gens intégrer cet indicateur c'est le
cas de yucca dont la cofondatrice julie
chapin et yvelinoise elle est notre
invité les derniers chiffres du chômage
révélée hier font état d'une
amélioration au premier trimestre 2009 1
t 1 dans les yvelines le territoire une
direction départementale de l'emploi du
travail et des solidarités vient d'être
lancé elle a pour objectif de rapprocher
mission d'insertion sociale et insertion
professionnelle interview à suivre et
puis des orties dans votre tisane c'est
l'idée de deux jeunes des mureaux qui
ont lancé leurs propres marques tous des
terres propose des boissons chaudes à
base des feuilles de cette plante
prélevés directement dans leur ville
focus
à la fin de ce journal tout à l'heure
également présentation du plan vélo de
la communauté urbaine grand paris seine
et oise il prévoit notamment la création
de plus de 126 km de pistes cyclables
mais pour débuter l'information a été
confirmé emmanuel macron s'exprimera ce
vendredi et 30 avril sur la crise
sanitaire c'est le premier ministre jean
castex qui l'annoncé ce mercredi matin à
la sortie du conseil de défense
sanitaire et du conseil des ministres le
président présentera une stratégie de
sortie progressive et phase et des
restrictions sanitaires
on ne connaît pas encore la forme de son
intervention interview allocution un
calendrier qui devrait se faire en
quatre étapes entre le 3 mai fin
officielle des limitations de
déplacements et la fin juin possible fin
du couvre-feu pour début juin à un plan
national est pour l'heure toujours
préféré mais le gouvernement n'exclut
pas des mesures territorialisée en
fonction de l'évolution de la crise
sanitaire
le président de la république qui
assistera demain jeudi aux obsèques de
stéphanie aime à saint-léger-en-yvelines
cette fonctionnaire de police assassiné
vendredi dernier au commissariat de
rambouillet on apprend d'ailleurs ce
mercredi qu'une cagnotte en ligne a été
lancée sur litchi au bénéfice de la
famille de la victime
c'est une initiative de l'amicale des
policiers d'elancourt rambouillet trappe
ce mercredi soir près de 6000 euros
avait déjà pu être récoltés si vous
souhaitez participer rendez vous sur le
lien qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
pour rappel à un hommage national aura
lieu également vendredi en matinée à
rambouillet et présidée par jean castex
et dans l' enquête sur l'attaqué menée
par le parquet national anti terroriste
il n'y a désormais plus de gardes à vue
en cours les deux dernières ont été
levées il s'agissait des deux cousins du
terroriste interpellées samedi et
dimanche
cinq personnes en tout avaient été
placés en garde à vue depuis les faits
parmi lesquels le père de l'assaillant
est un couple qui l'avait domicilié à
l'individu de 36 ans a été abattu à
l'attack après l' attaque au
commissariat de rambouillet inconnu des
services de renseignement il n'avait pas
de casier judiciaire à l'auteur dont la
radicalisation était peu contestable
selon les mots du procureur national
anti terroriste présentaient des
troubles de la personnalité
connaître son empreinte écologique au
travers des aliments que l'on consomme
l'écho score pourrait vous aider à y
voir plus clair il s'agit d'un
indicateur pour rendre plus transparents
l'impact environnemental d'un produit
les précisions de justin brasier à
l'image du nutrisse corps qui mesure la
qualité nutritionnelle d'un produit
alimentaire l'écho score luis en
mesurant l'impact environnemental de la
même façon les produits sont classés de
a à e selon un code couleur à
représentant un faible impact du produit
par exemple des fruits et légumes
origine france auront tendance à avoir
un faible impact environnemental avec un
code couleur vert tandis que la viande
importée aura tendance à avoir un
mauvais échos score l'objectif de cet
indicateur rendre l'empreinte écologique
que génèrent les produits transparents
mais aussi sensibiliser sur les modes de
consommation
elle nous avons interrogé les yvelinois
pour savoir si un écho score pourrait
changer leur manière de consommer
regardez j'ai lu d'ailleurs un article
il ya quelques mois sur l'apparition de
ce système là
oui c'est un grand projet c'est certain
et commencent à filtrer un petit peu en
france auprès de certains produits
à ce moment là oui je privilégie avec la
qualité fallait qu'au score pas désempli
je pense que ça peut changer ma manière
de consommer s'il est mis sur les
produits que comme pour le nitrile score
je le regarderai donc peut-être ça
changera certaines choses je vais suivre
ce qu'il sera mis sur les produits
c'est important pour l'environnement
pour le futur de la planète pour pour
des enfants qui arrivent
l'écho score est basé sur une
méthodologie il s'appuie sur les données
des analyses de cycle de vie des
produits qui a été réalisé par l' agence
de l'environnement et de la maîtrise
d'énergie
elle calcule un score sur 100 à partir
de plusieurs critères comme par exemple
la recyclabilité des emballages ou
encore l'origine à des produits
plusieurs acteurs de l'alimentation ont
d'ores et déjà lancé cette
fonctionnalité depuis le début de
l'année c'est le cas par exemple de
scanner open food fight ou encore une
cas et on parle de l'éco score avec
julie chapon bonsoir le poncer
yvelinoise originaire de verdun
verneuil-sur-seine et surtout
co-créatrice cofondatrice de yucca c'est
une application qu'on présente plus 22
millions d'utilisateurs dans le monde du
hockey nous renseigne sur les produits
alimentaires et cosmétiques pour en
savoir un peu plus sur leur qualité et
la création de cet éco score on le
rappelle a été plébiscité par la
convention citoyenne sur le climat elle
s'inscrit également dans le cadre d'une
expérimentation lancée par le ministère
de la transition écologique est prévue
dans la loi climat et résilience mais
l'initiative est venue surtout de dix
acteurs de l'alimentation dont yucca qui
propose cette fonctionnalité de l'écho
ce corps et dans son application
pourquoi justement cet engagement il ya
deux principales raisons pour laquelle
on s'est lancés chauffer la création de
ces mecs au score le premier c'est qu'il
ya un vrai enjeu environnemental
lle aujourd'hui à notre système
alimentaire aujourd'hui il faut savoir
que la production alimentaire mondiale
ça représente 28 % des émissions de gaz
à effet de serre et 70% de la
consommation en août dans le monde
donc il ya un vrai enjeu environnemental
lié au système alimentaire ça c'est la
première raison la deuxième raison c'est
pour la vie une très forte demande de
nos utilisateurs
c'est à dire que nos utilisateurs
d'utiliser l'application pour analyser
l'impact des produits sur la santé mais
était très demandeur d'avoir également
une information sur environnemental de
leurs potes
voilà compris un impact environnemental
qui est donc négatif on va dire de la
bonne part de la production la
production alimentaire urgence d'agir
les objectifs vous l'avez dit ça vient
d'une demande de vos consommateurs
on imagine dans un premier temps
informer les consommateurs il ya
peut-être aussi la volonté d'insuffler
une dynamique auprès des géants de
l'alimentation
effectivement il ya vraiment un double
objectif à c'était costaud corp le
premier c'est de permettre aux
consommateurs de s'orienter vers une
alimentation durable en les informant
mieux
le deuxième objectif c'est bien sûr
d'inciter les industriels à améliorer la
performance environnementale de leurs
produits l'idée c'est un peu de
répliquer ce qu'on a réussi aujourd'hui
à faire sur la dimension santé ou les
industriels ont beaucoup revu la
composition de leurs produits en grande
partie grâce à y bien
et donc on espère aussi que on aura le
même effet grâce à les scores sur la
dimension environnement vous avez bon
espoir que ces géants de
l'agroalimentaire puisse modifier
peut-être leur mode de production qui
est moins d'impact justement sur sur
l'environnement oui on a beau n'être pas
parce que même si les causes score est
lancée depuis peu on voit déjà des
impacts
pourquoi parce que par exemple dans
l'écho score on va prendre en compte
l'origine des ingrédients l'origine des
ingrédients
c'est une information qui n'est pas
obligatoire sur l'emballage et dans
l'application campile le l'industriel et
n'affiche pas l'information med-it des
affaires la possibilité de solliciter la
marque directement via le cas pour lui
demander une information de la provence
et beaucoup de marques communiquer ces
informations aient beaucoup nous ont
indiqué qu'ils allaient revoir leur
approvisionnement pour s'approvisionner
de façon plus local alors on l'a compris
aussi avec la chronique précédente
l'écho score si notation de a à e une
couleur verte pour faible impact et pour
la lettre a eu pour la couleur rouge et
un fort impact sur l'environnement
comment est-il calculé cette éco score
quels sont les principes quels sont les
indicateurs qui sont prises en compte
alors pour calculer cet indicateur on
regarde en fait tous les impacts que va
vendre leurs produits tout au long de
son cycle de vie et donc on rencontre
énormément énormément de choses mais
pour synthétiser
on va notamment regarder tout ce qui est
production agricole à tous qui ensuite
transformation du produit à tout ce qui
est en balade tout ce qui est transport
et pour regarder tout ça et pour
calculer ce score on s'appuie notamment
sur les travaux de l'ademe qui m'y ont
été menées depuis maintenant plus de dix
ans l'ademe donc la tête de l'agencé
publique de
transition écologique et l'ademe a
réalisé une analyse de cycle de vie sur
2500 catégories de produits donc voilà
c'est vous beaucoup appuyé sur les
travaux de l'ademe pour réaliser cette
notation est très concrètement sur
l'application youtube comment le
retrouve cet ego score alors ces
disputes dans la même application
l'application existante quand vous
scannez un produit alors on est on parle
vraiment que des produits alimentaires
comme ce qu'elle est un produit vous
avez désormais une fiche santé et à côté
vous avez un anglais avec une fiche
environnement et vous retrouvez tout le
détail des éléments d'allocations et
s'attaque au score va être également
testé un c'est en tout cas l'article
premier du projet de loi climat et
résilience la phase expérimentale va
durer cinq ans maximum
juste une précision est ce que va y
avoir différents échos score ou
peut-être l'idée justement c'est de
mettre en commun toutes ces données pour
proposer un indicateur unique à l'avenir
alors l'idée de cette expérimentation
ces différents acteurs proposent
différents systèmes de notation et qu'à
la fin d'expérimentation l'ademe qui me
positionne vers tellement indicateurs
voilà aujourd'hui les gosses corps c'est
un score qui est quand même très
avancées on a beaucoup travaillé avec
l'ademe en étroite collaboration
mais voilà l'idée est vraiment de cette
expérimentation c'est qu'à la fin il ya
une un score qui soit plébiscitée et qui
n'existent pas diverses etc au score sur
le marché une dernière question vous
avez pas des sports justement que dans
les cinq prochaines années grand maximum
se soit rendu obligatoire
l'écho score j'ai bon espoir mais dans
tous les cas même si c'est pas rendue
obligatoire je pense que les marges des
industriels finiront par l'affiché quand
même comme ça a été le cas pour le nuc
risque or qui n'est pas obligatoire mais
qui finalement est aujourd'hui afficher
sur beaucoup beaucoup de produits
parce que en fait ils n'auront pas le
choix les consommateurs sont demandeurs
de l'information et voilà c'est tout
dans leur intérêt d'aller dans ce sens
là on a déjà des industriels et des
distributeurs avec l'onl et en contact
avec souhaite d'ores et déjà étudié la
possibilité d'afficher les faux score
sur leur corps d'origine donc peut-être
très bientôt dans quelques semaines la
mére l'écho score déjà sur quelques
produits
merci julie chapon d'avoir été avec nous
merci à vous et je le rappelle vous est
la cofondatrice de l'application yucca
on reste dans la thématique
environnementale avec bientôt la
création de plus de 126 km de pistes
cyclables par grand paris seine et oise
est la communauté urbaine a décidé
d'investir pour ce faire plus de 17
millions d'euros dans son plan vélo les
détails de célia 400 go 17 millions
d'euros pour créer plus de 80
itinéraires cyclables sur toute
l'agglomération grand paris seine et
oise c'est le projet du plan vélo validé
par la communauté urbaine
trois axes sont prioritaires d'ici 2025
d'abord la scène à vélo la future vélo
route qui doit relier paris au havre
passe par les yvelines ce sont un
million de cyclotouristes qui sont
attendus chaque année des aménagements
un dérives sont prévues
j'ai aussi donc un levier de
développement économique touristique
donc donc la seule navello sur
d'antiques à mode même si une rive de la
seine à l'autre qui est alterne parfois
rive droite rive gauche sur notre
territoire nous on a plus de 60km à deux
titulaires le long de la seine deuxième
volet du plan vélo sécurisé les pistes
et itinéraires cyclables autour des
lieux de l'enseignement comme par
exemple les collèges ou les lycées les
scolaires pourront emprunter ou des
nouvelles pistes entre leur domicile et
leur établissement et décès de ces de
renforcer et de sécuriser des
itinéraires de fête embraque nos enfants
afin le long des départementales parfois
à travers champs enfin troisième point
le stationnement cyclable indispensables
à la pratique du vélo chaque année 500 à
1000 nouvelles places seront créées
autour des grands équipements et dans
les quartiers commerçants début des
travaux en 2022 et la scène avec
devrait-elle être inauguré en septembre
prochain c'est un nouveau service créé
par l'état la direction départementale
de l'emploi du travail et des
solidarités
elle doit permettre de rapprocher
mission d'insertion sociale et mission
d'insertion professionnelle on écoute à
ce propos la directrice de cette
nouvelle entité interrogé par nicolas
landry est les propos compilées par
eléonore sinoquet la dette ça a été
créée le 1er avril à 2021
donc c'est la direction départementale
de l'emploi du travail et des
solidarités
et cette nouvelle direction est né de la
fusion entre la direction départementale
de la cohésion sociale et l'unité
départementale de la direccte c'est
justement pour réunir dans une même
direction
les compétences en matière d'emploi
d'accompagnement social de lutte contre
la pauvreté et le système de
l'inspection du travail
nous accompagnons les publics les plus
vulnérables pour leur parcours
d'insertion
donc pour leur accès au droit pour leur
accès au logement social pour leur
proposer des solutions d'hébergement
lorsque ces publics sont à la rue nous
travaillons en direction des publics qui
sont demandeurs d'emploi avec
l'opérateur pôle emploi les mixe les
missions locales etc
nous soutenons les entreprises nous les
accompagnons dans ce contexte de
mutations économiques et puis donc les
inspecteurs du travail contrôler les
activités des entreprises protègent les
salariés et conseille également les
entreprises
ce qui va changer en fait pour les
yvelinois c'est qu'il y aura une
coordination renforcée entre les équipes
qui s'occupe de l'accompagnement social
et de l'insertion professionnelle donc
c'est bien évidemment des réponses
beaucoup plus efficaces et des sorties
dans votre tisane c'est l'initiative
pour le moins originale lancée par deux
jeunes des mureaux après trois mois de
formation au sein de l'association
l'académie des pluriels manaré capot ont
créé leur propre marque d'infusion tous
des terres et depuis leurs projets de
cesse de grandir on en parle avec astrid
bergère et jo ça cale à l'origine une
rencontre manar capot et l'association
l'académie des pluriels croiser leur
chemin en octobre 2020 aux mureaux et
puis un projet celui qui mûrit depuis
plusieurs mois et aboutit à une marque
de tisanes à base d'orties alors pour
ces deux jeunes l'association y est pour
beaucoup
c'est une association qui met en place
des parcours de formation pour redonner
le pouvoir d'agir aux jeunes etc a créé
sur l'entrepreneuriat et du coup pendant
cette formation de trois mois on était
réuni avec plusieurs jeunes des
quartiers pour collaborer ensemble 4
gousses ont donc concocté pour tous des
terres ou citron hibiscus lauriers et un
accompagne les orties récupérer au sein
de leur ville qui leur était jusque là
inconnu
c'était une plante qu'on ne connaissait
pas et qu'on a découvert en étant en
place
en recherchant dans des espaces verts
quels types de portes on peut utiliser
et on s'est rendu compte qu'en fait la
sortie c'est considéré comme une
mauvaise note
alors que ces plantes de bienfaits les
premiers clients sont séduits
ce qui les pousse à suivre une autre
formation à la ruche de
saint-germain-en-laye nom aussi de nos
ventes et un auchan ou dans les marchés
et il ya beaucoup d
beaucoup de retours sur pourquoi on peut
tu n'y es pas voter jeunes c'est
magnifique c'est un beau projet c'était
gêne ici des mureaux et c'est continuer
nous a donné beaucoup de force en fait
sur soi en plus de la création d'une
boisson chaude
ces deux jeunes issus des quartiers
populaires veulent d'agir dans le social
il souhaite embaucher des personnes en
difficulté ou éloignés de l'emploi et
voit les choses en grand
on aimerait pouvoir être déjà dans un
premier temps une marque reconnue et
pouvoir par la suite créer une sorte de
bar à tisanes associatif où l'on
pourrait en fait vendre naughty dog et
surtout à côté de mener des ateliers de
sensibilisation parce que c'est ça le
coeur de notre projet c'est que la
tisane fait surtout un outil de lien
social
trois bénévoles ont déjà rejoint le
projet l'objectif à long terme se
développer petit à petit pour peut-être
un jour devenir un peu plus grand et
s'étendre dans toute la france avant de
vous laisser direction voisins le
bretonneux pour franchir les portes du
magasin marquise et bergères et y
rencontrer laurence baby spécialiste de
la tapis de la tapisserie la décoration
intérieure elle vient de décrocher le
prestigieux titre de maître artisan
nicolas landry l'interroger
[Musique]
je m'appelle laurence baby j'ai 53 ans
et j'ai fondé marquise hébergeurs en
[Musique]
c'est une activité en deux parties une
activité qui concerne le métier de
tapissier décorateur donc fauteuil
réfection de fauteuils de siège de
canapés et aussi tout ce qui est des
corps de fenêtres voilages rideaux ou
stores bateau par exemple et l'autre
partie est une
l'activité de décoration d'intérieur
avec du conseil autour de la vente de
peintures et de papier peint souvent et
on refait le fauteuil à partir de sa
carcasse lorsqu'on appelle la carcasse
et le fus donc on leur semble on leur
met avec du ressort là vous pouvez voir
derrière moi il doit y avoir un fauteuil
avec du sel en crin donc ça c'est une
garniture dit traditionnel pique et
ensuite avec de lambour sûrs
notre projet force est d'avoir travaillé
avec le château de breteuil depuis 2016
où on a eu quand même 80 mètres de tissu
des échafaudages pour poser les rideaux
assure qu'on était à 6 mètres sous
plafond et un peu près 20 kg par pardo
uniquement l'aventuré entreprenariale
pour moi c'était la possibilité d'être
indépendante d'être autonome et de prime
abord c'était la possibilité de redonner
une deuxième vie à des objets qui
m'était confiée la possibilité de
recréer des sièges et de les rendre
clients en voyant
l'ancien qui pétillent et d'autre part
de faire aussi un petit peu de création
avec par exemple cette chipie fauteuil
qui a été trouvés dans les poubelles et
qu'on va remettre en état et qui pourra
même être mis à la vente par la suite et
d'autre part le faire savoir c'est la
possibilité de passer sa compétence
jeunes qui est motivé voilà c'est la fin
de ce journal merci de votre fidélité à
suivre ce soir sur tv 78 un nouveau
numéro du 7 8 sociétés astrid berges
heures et ses invités ils parleront
handicapés culture avec la diffusion
d'un documentaire
ce sera à retrouver à partir de 20h
belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]